i blew his entire body apart and his
limbs fly off how do you track how do
you track anything
the animation looks ridiculous that was
easy the hard part here is the
transformation i'm curious to know how
you think this one was done because i
watched it i think i figured it out but
i want to hear you guys
[Music]
thanks to noon for sponsoring this video
stick around to see how you can get your
free noom evaluation hey what's up
everybody we're back i'm back it's vfx
artist react we got joe ferrell sitting
on the couch he's a vfx supervisor right
he's a very good vfx supervisor because
he's done a lot of movies that you know
and love transformers wolf of wall
street irobot you made a robot cry so
we're going to be asking joe about all
the crazy stuff he's worked on hopefully
he'll reveal some cool secrets about how
he got some of these crazy shots and
some fun stories from i guess your
decades of being in the industry yeah i
got some fun ones some that i can say
and some that i can't
[Laughter]
all right let's jump in let's just jump
on in
so you were nominated for an oscar for
your working hereafter that's correct as
nominees most often say it's just great
to be nominated but we did work with one
of my idols director clint eastwood and
hereafter was done at a different
company scanline we got the job mainly
because scanline has this amazing
software called flowline where we can do
water simulation and water simulation
back then was possible but hard work
that's not good that's a big water sound
the first 10 minutes of the movie is
recreating the 2004 horrible tsunami
that wiped into indonesia and all the
islands down there and killed a horrible
number of people
this shot is crazy yeah this is this
these are incredible achievements in
terms of visual effects especially for
10 years ago not to mention like how do
you track how do you track anything
for match moving or camera tracking
there needs to be defined points of
geometry in space and those points get
tracked to conclude where the camera is
when it is taking that frame but if you
have no defined concrete points in your
scene in other words if you're seen as
water and then a clear sky there are
zero tracking points with which you can
use that geometry to rebuild your scenes
so how the heck do you track a camera
yeah clint in this particular instance
grabbed a camera jumped into the ocean
and he just sort of filmed it with him
on his shoulders with the camera out of
frame and he's with the actress just
waiting in and trying to act through the
performance with the waves and the
advantage is is because you can't track
anything you also have no point of
reference that you need to track it so
what really needs to happen is you just
need to make the camera do what you want
it to do and then it's just hand
rotating the waves and the water and the
splashes so you guys can kind of get
away
with not really having to worry about
matching the motion too much when
putting her into the crazy swirling
river you need to check the general gist
now the human body is very forgiving as
far as perspectives concerned you can
get away with sort of breaking the rules
of what the camera can do up to like 10
to 15 percent probably it's always about
manipulating the image to the quickest
best photographic method to try and get
there in the end i'm just blown away at
how good this looks and also the fact
that you're rotoing water
the tricky part was making real water
blend through to cg water so that's when
compositing comes in but you need access
to the cg asset to be able to modify it
without breaking the characteristics of
water water has reflection refraction
transparency and different kinds of
gradients for instance at one point two
rivers combine and one of them is dirty
and one of them's clean and the
simulation needed to happen between them
to blend so a lot of work was done with
pulling the water apart and putting it
back together again in the comp so that
we could blend all of that
but what we're also needing to do is
we're needing to tell a story so there's
a shot here where we start on them and
they're spinning while the camera moves
with them so in reality it's just the
two of them going ah
like that but the camera needed to go
from here to here well there's no reason
that the camera and them aren't in a
whirlpool spinning sure so we previous
all of this and designed it and then
simulations the trees are seeming all
the debris is seeming in the surface but
we're also swimming deeper into the
surface so that we can figure out how
the debris moves and floats and moves
around it
the guy reaching out to her that's just
a dude on a green box oh really so the
interesting thing is that the hard
surfaces were rendered separately from
the ocean so we needed those two pieces
to sell each other when you say hard
surfaces you mean like all the actual
objects yes the wood and the cars the
wood the simulations the cars slamming
into buildings but the disadvantage of a
broken out thing is they're unaware of
each other and so trying to sell all
that together is where the compositing
team comes together and really sells all
this stuff with water caustics and
lighting and shadows and gradients and
pulling this stuff apart to put it all
back together
why couldn't you just render it all out
as one thing back then mainly because of
the fact that we're integrating the live
action you're trying to also work with
getting photo realism in there and some
things that come out of the render
aren't photo reel well if you try and
put all of those calculations into
machines that we were running back then
on the racks 11 12 years ago you
wouldn't have had those renders out of
the farm so in order to render that well
let's shave a few of these things off
render that out render this out pull it
into the comp and then the comp artist
goes and puts it back in that's
something the digital domain did on
irobot my father tried to teach me human
emotions they are difficult wetter and
digital domain approached the
transparent marquette of the robot very
differently wedder rendered it out with
their hardcore lord of the rings render
farm where they would run ray-traced
caustics breaking up through this
plastic mesh digital domain built this
thing very very complicated intricate
gizmo in nuke where all the renders
would render it out into pieces and they
would be combined in a comp script the
beauty of that was we were able to tweak
it left right and center without ever
going back into the render farm hell i
don't want my toaster or my vacuum
cleaner appearing emotional i did not
murder him so sunny in that for instance
we needed to read the nose we needed to
see the curl of the lip and if they
rendered that straight up as a ray trace
all of that stuff would have pushed
through it and we would have done
iteration after the interaction after
iteration i see so you're always
essentially rendering in parts in case
you need to go in and tweak so by having
the kind of like silicone outer shell as
like a separate path so to speak really
let you work with your transparency and
the light on it to really pull out the
facial features as needed on the shot by
shot exactly interpretive basis yeah
you have to do what someone asks you
don't you detective spooner but in this
one he he goes from angry
to crying the animation on this is
beautiful he's got a quivering you can
see his eyebrow clinching up there and
his lips quiver and then at the end i
actually was putting little tears these
little wells of clear oil some mineral
oil yeah some mineral oil or something
there then he starts to get a a little
teary you know robot cheese i thought
you maybe like just insulted his like
cpu saying like his hurts were too low
so he's dumb
maybe if only we could get a real robot
to a mate like well it's great because
you keep it subtle you know you're not
doing tears running down the robots
was there a take like that no no no no
no no it's pretty subtle we subtle we
push the boundaries in in movie making
it's great it's great
the mummy something about the mummy the
mommy keeps showing up in all of our vfx
reactor the mummy is great i think we
all like working on them because it's
just so slapstick and hilarious and we
had fun here like we burnt sheets of
plastic cheese to make jet li explode
now you can rule
in hell
all right look at those cheeks
little flames little flames start
shooting out of his cheeks
and then boom
i blew his entire body apart and his
limbs fly off wait so you got the cheesy
cheeks going and did you is that the
actual footage of cheeks or did you just
reference so i found a really good
technique for doing it which is
basically you get a mesh of a face but
what you can do is you can unwrap the
uvs from the face you've now got this
weird distorted uv face and then what
you do is you then just simply put down
your cheese and then you 2d track it and
then you just re-wrap your cheese
burning with that new track back onto
the mesh and stick it back on and bob's
your uncle tracking instantly that's a
great technique i never that that's
amazing i've also heard that this is a
lot of what is done for a lot of
de-aging and digital makeup these days
at places like lola and a lot of other
studios yeah exactly yeah dude the lava
through the eyes that is brutal that's
one way to go hand tracking all the fire
onto the various armor we just set fire
to some bits and pieces and then i had
to track all the hands yeah the fire on
the body looks yeah the hands looks
really good doing real fire is hard work
and you guys often bring it up and i i
always giggle when i see it but it's
really difficult to shoot fire
practically to do what you want in the
shot but if you simulate the fire the
sim has got shape a lot of times you can
take the real fire and do some shaping
to it so you sort of shape real fire
shape real sim combine the two in comp
and you won't end up with that sort of
problem where you're trying to fight the
photography and you won't end up with
the fire being different levels and the
fire not looking right that's a solid
technique damn
your bed buddy alice
there's a shot here in transformers
which is one of the gnarliest shots i've
ever worked on this was like the like
four seconds for four years kind of this
situation i took nine months to do a
shot that's four seconds long
it's a lot of detail on this shot yes
okay the animation looks ridiculous that
was easy the hard part here is the
transformation you can see all these
tiles and all these maps so we take
projections put them onto the tiles
those tiles then need to lock her
performance and you can see they pull
from her form to the robot's form you're
essentially having to blend between her
footage and she's mapped on to a 3d
version of her that's flipping in
and then you have the robot kind of
flipping out and you have to blend those
two together yeah but it doesn't all
happen as one piece so it progresses
from her hands down her inside chest
happens and then her face does it all
individually because these are just
renders like i just get a render of all
the tiles of her doing their thing and
then i get a render of all the tiles
going from the inside pieces turning
down to the robot and then the robot
gets from the robot pieces back into its
piece then there's shadows then there's
reflections then there's all this sorts
of stuff that goes into it so this shot
was by far one of the most complicated
shots i've worked on goodness like in my
mind
when i'm doing any sort of shot like
this and it's the most basic andrew
kramer video co-pilot version of this
even that is daunting to think about and
like this is the most advanced version
of that you're blowing my mind here you
blow my mind like three or four times
just with the sheer amount of work that
you're putting into this luckily they
don't tell us that it's going to be nine
months when we first get awarded the
shot they're like joe we want you to do
this cool transformation of this girl
transforming into a robot i'm like that
sounds cool and then nine months later
i'm like
if there's any consolation this is one
of the effect shots that i distinctly
remember from the movie oh good it was
that good
oh this one i'm curious to know how you
think this one was done because i
watched it i think i figured it out but
i want to hear you guys all right i love
a good puzzle
[Music]
it's not often i watch a shot and i'm
like i don't know how they did it
wow
we're not done yet
i've watched it it took me 20 times
before i think i got like 85 percent of
it figured out all right here's nico's
uh wild shot in the dark
opening with a helicopter shot slash cg
it's the building of the smoke coming
out of it i think there's a scene
between that neighborhood that we're
looking at there in the city that's in
front of it two separate passes
basically but as we keep going here
we're in a drone shot now and then
somewhere around here is a transition to
a crane shot maybe or if you see a very
slight wobble it could just be a classic
bring the drone down and catch it
and now somebody's walking with a gimbal
so there might be a handoff from a crane
to a steady cam operator or there is one
of the cleverest blends i've ever seen
why isn't this possible to do
practically for real uh because you'd
put actors at risk if that's a drone a
drone yeah you cannot fly a drone
anywhere near performance they're
shooting with aries probably if you're
shooting the arri you need a very heavy
duty drone and that drone is one very
loud yeah
very heavy and boy i've seen those
things lose control oh yeah and so you
know those things are
tricky and they do beautiful things but
if it's a lightweight drone you wouldn't
get an image this nice no you wouldn't
you could throw a gopro or maybe even
like black magic or something like that
on there but it wouldn't look like an
airy what's stopping them from lowering
a steadicam operator
down holding and filming i could see a
possibility of attaching a ronin to a
drone the drone comes down and you
magnetically pull the ronin off a drone
and then you become a steady cam as you
move back and the drone just gets out of
there actually eliminate the drone i
think you had it figured out though
potentially you hook up like a ronin
onto a cable the cables are oh it's a
cable cap you can control those remotely
so the guy's just sitting on the screen
watching it you know maybe it's wobbling
stuff like that but the road is going to
keep itself stable yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's a cable cam with a
magnetic switch goes over to a ronin at
a steady cam bam figured it out thank
you very much
now i can sleep now we could have this
completely wrong hey if you worked on
the shot shoot us an email or something
we'd love to figure it out that'd be
great
hats off well done that was really
nicely done what's one of your favorite
vfx shots from something that you didn't
do didn't do the work in gravity had me
just from one side to the other side
just going oh my goodness
just give them the oscar because it was
just stunning work there's a trailer for
star trek the new j.j abrams one and i
think it's probably one of the best
trailers i've ever seen in my life it is
from the beginning to the end
emergency invasive fire everything
like i'm not a star trek fan but i watch
the trailer and i'm just like man it
just makes me want to make movies and do
cool stuff so
you know it's a it's a passion that
comes from just constantly being inaud
by new things that come out june and
that's a friend of mine paul lambert
who's the supervisor he's got so many
oscars now it's ridiculous he's swimming
yeah yeah he's swimming and like excuse
me duck except it's a bunch of like
little
spikes and paul is one of the hardest
working people so he and i were similar
positions at digital domain and he went
on to great things because he's just an
absolute rock star yeah that director
he's my favorite in terms of style and
tone that like dark style dark tone is
the best the opening shot to blade
runner the original film
by far my most favorite shot of all time
and the reason being is i got to meet
the model maker who did all the actuals
he worked at digital maine les ecker and
he was one of the guys that put all the
little fiber optics
into all those brass etched pieces just
old school techniques like this i just
love what's up everybody i'm back to
talk about that little sensitive subject
weight loss and with today's sponsor new
i'm going to tell you a little bit about
my journey i actually started my whole
weight loss journey in march of last
year i started my journey at 2 54 and
just this morning i weighed up at 2 29
but it took me a really long time a lot
of hard work to get past that 230 number
and uh noon really helped me get there
so i'm going to tell you about a lot of
the cool tools and stuff that they have
that help me get over those humps so
nume is a science-based psychology type
app it's not a dieting app but it is a
science-based app that helps you make
small changes in your daily life to have
a better relationship with food and
exercise and overall health neum is not
about the quick program or the recent
fad i've done some of the fad diets
they're not sustainable you know you can
i'm never going to swear off cookies
forever and noon doesn't ask me to do
that room is all about the small daily
decisions that promote sustainable
long-term change no joke i literally use
new every day i'm able to track my food
through their food tracking and color
system green yellow red you know red
foods you're supposed to really limit
yellow you can kind of eat in moderation
and green go ham so it's a total like
psych trick that they've taught me
that's just like oh man am i do i really
want to eat this if i have to log it and
it's going to be red you know like do i
really want to lose that that progress
that i've made noom also pairs with your
favorite health tracking app i have a
ring here it tracks my activity so then
it actually gives me an accurate calorie
budget every day that i'm supposed to
kind of hit or stay with it shout out to
jennifer my personal coach she's
actually like a one-on-one line i can go
to whenever i have kind of questions and
stuff she's never trying to tell me this
is exactly how things are going and this
is how new says you have to do things
because that's not what noon does noon's
trying to help me change my mindset and
my relationship with food and exercise
and they also have group classes i know
this is a nerve-wracking subject to
tackle but if you're ready to take
charge and make some sustainable
lifestyle changes in your overall diet
and health check out new i have lost 25
pounds since i started this whole
journey and neum has been a huge help so
if you're interested go to the link
description down below and you can take
your free new evaluation and get your
own customized program set up just for
you let's start making some real changes
let's do this together and you guys can
hit me up at any time i'd love to see
updates and progress uh you will
continue to see them from here from me
so i hope everybody enjoys it and until
then let's get back to the episode so we
often ask for what are your favorite
shots from films tv shows classic films
i would love to know where where's your
favorite vfx from youtube videos and
other online creators i'd love to do a
breakdown of some of the stuff that
we've seen on youtube from some of the
wonderful digital artists here joe thank
you immensely for joining us yes it was
my pleasure anytime you guys want to
invite me onto this therapeutic couch
i'm here don't forget to also check out
clint's channel at youtube.com shirt
yeah i'm you know teaching people how to
do vfx in my weird way so come on over
hanging out it's a good time all right
joe thank you so much
thank you for watching thank you so much
we'll see you either this sunday
tomorrow because we have another video
usually on sundays or next saturday if
you don't watch our other videos for
some reason
[Laughter]
see you around and see you around